what is vertex AI model Garden
model Garden is a single place to
discover and interact with Google's
industry-leading models and popular open
source models with Google Cloud's
Enterprise mlops tooling support built
in
with all these different Enterprise
ready models you could use model Garden
allows you to choose the right model for
your use case ml expertise and budget
from monogarden you can kick off a
variety of workflows including using a
model directly as an API tuning the
model in the generative AI Studio using
the model directly in a jupyter notebook
through vertex AI workbench or help you
deploy model training Pipelines